>>> THIS JUST IN.
ELON MUSK IS SUSPENDING THE
TWITTER ACCOUNTS OF SOME OF THE
JOURNALISTS WHO COVER TWITTER,
AMONG THEM MEMBERS OF THE "NEW
YORK TIMES," "WASHINGTON POST,"
AND CNN.
DONIE O'SULLIVAN REPORTED HERE
LAST NIGHT ON THE CONTROVERSIAL
SUSPENSION OF A DIFFERENT
ACCOUNT JUST HAD HIS ACCOUNT
SUSPENDED.
DONIE, LAST NIGHT YOU WERE
SITTING HERE REPORTING ON THE
YOUNG GUY WHO IS TRACKING -- HAS
BEEN TRACKING THE PRIVATE JET OF
ELON MUSK.
THAT'S HIM.
YOU DID AN INTERVIEW WITH HIM
AND HIS GRANDMOTHER --
>> CORRECT.
>> -- AND APPARENTLY ELON MUSK
DID NOT LIKE THAT.
>> YEAH.
SO, WHAT'S BASICALLY HAPPENED IS
THAT JUST REALLY OVER THE PAST
HOUR OR SO, AS THE NUMBER OF
JOURNALISTS AT NATIONAL NEWS
OUTLETS, INCLUDING "THE NEW YORK
TIMES," "WASHINGTON POST," AND
HERE AT CNN, HAVE BEEN
PERMANENTLY, IT SEEMS, SUSPENDED
FROM TWITTER.
NOW, ALL THOSE JOURNALISTS,
INCLUDING MYSELF, HAPPEN TO BE
PEOPLE WHO COVER ELON MUSK.
THIS IS ELON MUSK, OF COURSE,
THE FREE SPEECH ACTIVIST.
>> YEAH, LIKE THAT.
>> THE FIRST AMENDMENT.
DREW HARWELL, WHO'S ONE OF THE
REPORTERS AT THE "WASHINGTON
POST" WHO IS SUSPENDED PUT OUT A
STATEMENT SAYING, ELON SAYS HE
IS BANNING JOURNALISTS FOR
EXERCISING FREE SPEECH.
I THINK THAT CALLS INTO QUESTION
HIS COMMITMENT.
AND LOOK, I MEAN, THIS IS -- YOU
KNOW, AS WE SAW WITH THE JET
TRACKER LAST NIGHT, MUSK SEEMS
TO BE STAMPING OUT ACCOUNTS THAT
HE DOESN'T LIKE.
>> WHICH IS, I MEAN, KIND OF
CRAZY, GIVEN HIS --
>> HIS STANCE ON SPEECH.
>> -- HIS LINE.
I THINK WE HAVE AN IMAGE OF YOUR
ACCOUNT.
>> YEAH.
SO, THAT'S WHAT I SEE WHEN I TRY
TO LOG IN RIGHT NOW.
IT SAYS, YOUR ACCOUNT IS
CURRENTLY SUSPENDED.
IT SAYS, AFTER CAREFUL REVIEW,
THEY DECIDED TO KICK ME OFF THE
PLATFORM.
IN THE MINUTES LEADING UP TO THE
SUSPENSION, WE WERE REPORTING --
WE WERE DOING OUR JOB.
WE WERE REPORTING ON WHAT WAS
HAPPENING WITH THE MUSK JET
SITUATION.
MUSK HAD CLAIMED, AS KIND OF A
JUSTIFICATION FOR TAKING DOWN
THE JET ACCOUNT, THAT THERE WAS
AN INCIDENT THIS WEEK INVOLVING
HIS CHILD IN LOS ANGELES.
HE CLAIMED THAT A STALKER, HE
DESCRIBED IT, FOLLOWED THE CAR
HIS CHILD WAS IN, AND HE TRIED
TO LINK THIS TO THE JET TRACKING
APP.
IT'S NOT CLEAR THERE IS A
LINKAGE THERE.
NEVERTHELESS, JUST A FEW MINUTES
BEFORE WE GOT KICKED OFF
TWITTER, I HAD REPORTED THAT THE
LOS ANGELES POLICE DEPARTMENT
SAID THEY WERE AWARE OF THE
SITUATION AND BY THE TWEET BY
ELON MUSK AND WAS IN CONTACT
WITH HIS REPRESENTATIVES AND HIS
SECURITY TEAM.
AND THEY DID POINT OUT THAT NO
CRIME REPORTS HAVE BEEN FILED
YET.
BUT, LOOK, I MEAN, I THINK, IN
TERMS OF ME PERSONALLY, MANY OF
THE NATIONAL REPORTERS, "THE
TIMES," AND "THE POST," WE'RE
OKAY.
I'M ON "THE ANDERSON COOPER
SHOW."
WE HAVE A PLATFORM.
JUST LIKE WHEN TRUMP GOT KICKED
OFF, WE CAN POST ELSEWHERE